[Music]
well let's talk about the upgrades to an
airport you know las vegas has one of
the nation's busiest airports reed
international has the seventh most
passengers in the u.s for a long time
you've heard clark county talk about
building a second airport to handle that
growing demand the question is when will
that project finally take off
in 1948 it was the outskirts what we now
call reed international airport out on
its own in the south part of town
it's not alone anymore we are growing
robin armstrong works for clark county's
department of aviation she's responsible
for guiding reed through its growing
pains so in addition to being landlocked
there's only so much room for expansion
and we've basically capped at that point
the airport has expanded relentlessly
since the mid 90s but even back then
clark county could see las vegas growing
around the airport and another solution
was necessary as long as the projected
growth continues the way that it has
been and demand continues then yes the
need will be there it's here the ivanpah
valley near prim clark county owns six
thousand acres to build another airport
at this site
armstrong presented these revised plans
to the commission last month showing the
footprint of what the facility could
look like we will service the same
clients at that airport that we do here
now armstrong says the proof is in the
numbers since 2010 reed international
seen a steady growth of passengers from
a 3.6 million to a record 4.6 million in
2019.
after the pandemic setback the airport
is right back where it was
it'll be a while armstrong believes
it'll be another 15 years in fact before
this second airport is built however the
work is underway now so las vegas
doesn't miss its connection with the
future the demand will be there and we
want to be prepared
so you're probably asking yourself hey
how much is that airport going to cost
that new one down south well
unfortunately keep wondering armstrong
says it is way too early to project a
price clark county could also buy
another 17 000 acres of land from the
blm around that airport site near prim
just to make sure it doesn't get crowded
as well